Carli Lloyd last night the US Women's
National Team in front of that crowd at
the link picked up the wind their
inaction in st. Paul Minnesota
that'll be tonight on espn2 it's 7:00
central and they're expecting more than
47,000 on hand karlie good morning how
are you today good how you doing I'm
doing okay
I'm curious how this became sort of
something fun something interesting to
know maybe something serious about
trying to kick in the NFL when can you
give us sort of the progression of this
yes been kind of crazy
you know I got invited to go out to
Eagles practice I happen to have off
that day so it worked out really well
and I went out with my husband Brian and
my coach and mentor his younger son
Preston I also knew the or another
Ravens kickin coach and special teams
coach who used to be a former mayor a
couple towns over for me so he's been
trying to get me to come out and kick
with Justin Tucker over the last couple
of years so finally all things aligned I
was able to go when the Eagles were
practicing against the Ravens brought my
boots because I was just going to have
some fun kicking some vehicles strapped
up you know put my boots on and just
started kicking field goals I didn't
really warm up I started at 25 yards and
nailed that one and just kept moving
further and further back got set at the
55 yard line and hit that one straight
off the bat and then you know next thing
I know I'm getting in the car to leave
several you know an hour later so and
things just started blowing up and going
viral and it turned into you know
potentially playing in the NFL and it's
been it's been just wild you know the
power of social media and just just
crazy really I so what was the
discussion like with your husband you
know I think when when I got home and
you know my phone was blowing up with
all sorts of texts and tweets and
I was just kind of laughing and thinking
this is just you know something fun and
my husband was actually saying you know
this this is pretty big I mean you
should seriously consider it so he's you
know he's all for it I just was kind of
brushing it off but I think the more and
more that I think about it it would be
pretty amazing
number one to be the first female to
kick in the NFL to break break that
barrier and maybe pave the way for some
other include female cookers and I love
a challenge and I don't you know
whatever challenge comes my way I don't
shy away from it I actually grace it and
with the right training and the right
technique and and all of that it's a
possibility and I'm not naive to know
that there's some big men that play
football you know and obviously I wasn't
trying out for the NFL when I was
kicking this field goal so I took
multiple steps because I was just having
fun with it
so I'd like to get out there I'd like to
actually really try to get you know a to
step down if I can do that then there is
a great possibility but first and
foremost you know I am focusing on
soccer at the moment and do you want to
be a part of the Olympic team and that's
sort of my goal right now would you have
to retire from the u.s. women's soccer
team to focus on this you know I'm I'm
not really sure I'm not I'm not sure how
you know would work to have a u.s.
soccer contract and also an NFL contract
I'm not sure that they've ever run into
that problem before I would imagine that
you know I'd probably have to choose but
I think this is you know this is
something that it's going to depend on
the next coach coming in and if they see
me in their future plans for for the
Olympics and then I'll you know just
kind of go from there and figure it out
it feels like there are a lot of people
worried for you that if you have to
tackle somebody which I I found sexist
because I nobody ever says a field goal
kicker boy can he tackled
buddy you're you've dealt with the
physicality of playing soccer you you
play in a physical way it do you have
any concerns about this I mean of course
I mean I know that it does happen I
think that there there is you know less
of a chance of that happening but I know
that it does happen you know I think
that it you know there's a number of
different things you can kind of focus
on all that and you know or I could just
kind of attempt it and see what happens
but yeah I mean it it's different I mean
men are bigger stronger faster than than
women that's just kind of the DNA of men
versus women I get that I know that it's
obviously something that you know I
would have to think about as well but
you know I really really believe that
you know I have I have great form as far
as technique on the soccer field and you
know that that carries into kicking a
field goal as well you know I actually
was sent a screen shot of you know
Justin Tucker kicking and me kicking and
it's you know pretty similar technique
so I think with some practice and all
that there's definitely a possibility
all right you grew up in Eagles fan what
if the Dallas Cowboys wanted to bring
you in to have you try on or the New
York Giants somebody in this the
division or the Steelers they brought
you in which one would be tougher to do
that would be tough you know but at the
end of the day it's you know I it would
be you know a business decision I think
you know I haven't gotten that that far
yet but it would be it would be
difficult but at the end of the day you
know I'm a competitor and wherever if
the possibility I did land somewhere
other than the Eagles you know I just
would have to do my job and you know I
want to win and that's all it matters
did you imagine going
the link game on the line and then you
beat your Eagles and they don't get a
chance to go to the playoffs I'm just
you know that we're just having fun here
I'm fast-forwarding here car I know I
know I know you yeah people many people
are fast phone taking it all in
yeah but fritzy a hall-of-fame kicker
Morten Anderson's on the line for some I
saw where Morgan hey Morton how are you
hey Dan hey Carly hey how are you
appreciate the support it's my pleasure
and and I think then I want to say this
to everybody I think this is worth
celebrating and embracing and whether it
happens or not this is this is what
America's is all about I came from a
sock sock up rap background in Denmark
listen didn't know how to kick a
football until I came to this country
and it worked out pretty well for me so
Carly whether you work with Justin
Tucker or decide to if you want to come
and work with me and I'm just offering
up my services I think it's wonderful I
think it's it's more than fun because
you clearly have the talent your great
soccer player and we need to celebrate
strong humans whether female or male I
appreciate that
yeah you uh you've done quite well so I
mean and yeah that's awesome I
appreciate that Martin what kind of
advice there one tip if she has nine ten
months to get ready for something like
this what should she focus on I would
say that she put the helmet and chill
the pads on right away and get the feel
for kicking with the equipment on I
think that's that's going to be key
because it does change you know one
thing is to go out in shorts and a tank
top and and we we all have done that but
you need to put the equipment on to it
because it does change when you're
wearing you know wearing that so it
changes it a little bit but other than
that just be patient and it's it's a
long road it's a marathon and do your
due diligence Carly like it sounds like
you want to and take your time and and
you know it's it's really a lot of it is
between the years when when the lights
come on as you know and you've been in
big moments so but I would say put the
equipment on as quickly as you can
Morgan for that did anybody question
your ability to tackle anybody well and
let me say they called me the matador
for a reason so I don't think that's a
little concern for Carly I think we have
ten other guys in front of us for a
reason and your job is to put the ball
through the pipes through the uprights
and so whatever you if you want to run
to the sideline right after you kick I
don't have a problem with that it was a
nicer beauty to call in great to catch
up with you thank you we appreciate your
Tillett that's a yeah I really
appreciate it I'll get in touch with you
at some point
yeah Hall of Fame kicker he paid kick
for 25 years and they see the all-time
scoring leader I think in NFL history so
what did your teammates say last night
when you before you guys played I did
get any advice or anybody have anything
to say about this possibility yeah well
I had an you know just a few days ago
when I met up with the team obviously
that was the first thing that that
everybody was kind of talking about when
I walked walked into the hotel and I had
a lot of teammates who who supported me
and want me to do it and you know just
saying that you know I would live for
this moment and you don't do it you're
crazy
so they they have all my support and you
know it's pretty cool and for something
that just turned into a very casual
casual thing it's it's just unbelievable
how big this has gotten and yeah it's
it's been pretty cool
why don't you get Rapinoe to be your
holder I know that she'll tackle
somebody yeah oh yeah yeah I mean I've
got no issues tackling anybody either
but I don't know if I see it a three
under come man coming out me might be
might think a little otherwise I have
you worn shoulder pads in a helmet
before I have not okay now and
you know that is the first thing that I
do want to you know get on my selfie
equipment I actually need a bag of
footballs as well that's another thing
you obviously they don't have footballs
in my house a lot of soccer balls but
I'm sure that there'll be people who are
volunteering to help you with that
with your foot yeah yes hey it's fun I
hope it doesn't put added pressure on
you that you now have to do it I hope
it's something that you can enjoy and
you know maybe there's that possibility
of just getting in uniform getting out
on the field
that'd be wonderful to see but in the
meantime good luck tonight in in
Minnesota and we appreciate your time
Carly yeah thanks so much appreciate it
that's a Carli Lloyd for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]